foreign
the controversy the song has gained
popularity something other musicians are
Keen to capitalize on open lemonade
stand on the side wall go for a long
walk in the middle of the night keep
schools open so that kids can keep on
learning you think it's cool we'll lack
the Fool If You Lie poet someone's
groceries in a bag that doesn't
immediately break
don't bake a penis cake we'll try that
in a large Town see how far you make it
down the road
around here we're punishing our own
across that line it won't take long for
you to find out I recommend you don't
try that in a large town please
[Music]
call the line for non-emergencies cause
somebody's dropping trousers on your
daisies that stuff might fly in the
country good luck try that in a large
town
see how far you make it down the road
around here we speed camera around you
cross that line it won't take long for
you to
be beautiful I recommend you don't
try that in a large town
foreign
[Music]